La grande mosquée de Québec
a changé. Eltététété rénovée,
la sécurité y a été renforcée.
Mohamed Labidi aussi n'est pIlIt
du Centre culturel islamique
lors du drame qui a emporté
six de ses frères musulmans
le 29 janvier 2017.
MOHAMED LABIDI, ancien président
du Centre culturel islamiqueelel
drame. Ça, c'est quelque chose
qu'on va porter, je pense,
à vie. On essaie de tourner
difficulté.
- Au lendemain du drame,
ururururé de dignitaires,
il s'adressait aux Québécois
devant des dizjojojojojojojojoje
de Québec.
- Nous sommes très touchés
par cette solidarité et ça faite
notre chagrin, vraiment.
il se sent encore soulevépapapaé
des Québécois.
- Beaucoup de monde qui ont
révisé leur position. On le
vo
dans notre communauté le voit.
- À commencer par l'ancien maire
de Québec, Régis Labeaume, qui
est devenu l'un de leurs
meilleurs alliés.
- Le changement du maire
pour moi, j'ai vécu...
ilmmmmmmmmmmmme un 180 degrés.
- J'aurais de la place demain
à 4 h 30.d d d d d d d d d d d t
un salon de coiffure près de
la mosquée est du même avis.
MOHAMED KHABAR
- Il y a beaucoup de Québécoisqt
c'est quoi le vrai problème.
Le
les immigrants. C'est pas
l'immigrvrvrvrvrvrvrai problème,
c'est le racisme.
- Le soir fatidique,
une balle lui traversait
orteil. Il fait partie
des cinq blessésatatatatatatat.
- C'est pas fini et on a
du travail à faire en tant
que société.
- Selon les deux hommes, l'élan
de solen raison de politiques qs
jugent polarisantes.
- La loi 21, tu empêches
c'est quoi ca? C'est pas
. . . . . . . Tu vois, pour vive
ensemble, ce n'est pas ça
le modèle.
- Mohamed Labidi déplore aussi
que les gouvernements n'en font
pas assez pour protéger
sur les réseaux sociaux.- - - -e
les tragédies et
ce
Le Canada et le Québec n'ont
pas besoin de ça.
- Il ne comprend pas non plus
pourquoi c'est encore aussimemes
à feu au Canada.
Les deux Mohamed espèrent que
les dissensions politiques
a émergé de la tragédie.
- ntntntntntntntnt il continue,
il va avoir... une vie meilleure
ici.
- Mohamed Khabar a bon espoir
que son fils âgé de cinq ans
où s'épanouir.
-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-Pier Mercier,
Radio-Canada, Québe